like the point obviously if i had a  streak two points  okay it's not berserking anymore  okay  doing pretty well here  oh yes okay knight five is good  probably has bishop c5 and then roxy one  yeah he usually spots some little tricks  king of roxy fire actually queen d6  now i was intending to take on here and  roxy8  yeah i don't think he has any dangerous  hopefully he will spend some time  looking for some tactics here but i  don't think he has any  and exactly what i hope what happened  happened  i don't think this game anything at all  94 i just taken d5  probably shouldn't have allowed  oh tricky guy queen g3 if i took  always some tricks be one  and then it should be made  okay let's make the next